it was undoubtedly a contempt when he
released
details about their report
when he had received them in confidence
so that he could respond to them that's
just another contempt by Mr Johnson he
is just plays fast and loose with
anything which he doesn't wish to be
constrained by and I think that's what
comes out of this report I've obviously
only had time to read the summary uh in
in the time available since it was
published but it's completely damning I
thought the most damning thing was when
he stood up in the House of Commons and
said that he'd been given assurances
that the rules had been followed at
number 10 when he'd been specifically
told by his civil servants it was an
assurance he couldn't give
excuse me let's um share with our
viewers some of the things that he has
said in a three-page report he released
a lengthy statement uh the key excerpts
the committee now says that I
deliberately misled the house and at the
moment I spoke I was consciously
concealing from the house my knowledge
of illicit events this is rubbish it is
a lie in order to reach this deranged
conclusion the committee is obliged to
say a series of things that are patently
absurd or contradicted by the facts he
went on to say about the committee's
decision that their argument can be
boiled down to look at this picture
that's Boris Johnson with a glass in his
hand he must have known that the event
was illegal therefore he lied that is a
load of complete tripe that picture was
me in my place of work trying to
encourage and thank my officials in a
way that I believed was crucial for the
government and for the country as a
whole and in a way which I believe to be
wholly within the rules he ends by
saying this this report is a charade I
was wrong to believe in the committee or
its good faith the terrible truth is
that it is not I who has Twisted the
truth to suit my purposes it is Harriet
Harman and her committee this is a
dreadful day for MPS and for democracy
this decision means that no MP is free
from vendetta or expulsion on trump top
charges by a tiny minority who want to
see him or her gone from the commons
woof
notes on that well it is a dreadful day
to see a prime minister a former prime
minister attacking Parliament uh when
previously he said that the sovereignty
of Parliament and Parliament as an
institution was so important to him and
that's what I find extraordinary with
with Mr Johnson everything is fine
everything is important until he decides
it isn't the truth is this committee on
the evidence has done its very best to
look at the evidence of Mr Johnson's
misdoings and frankly the evidence
against Mr Johnson as prime minister is
overwhelming over partygate that he
misled the house the issue is never did
he have parties that's one thing the
issue is did he mislead the House of
Commons in answering questions at the
dispatch box in a manner that was going
to bring that brought him into the
contempt and it's absolutely abundantly
clear that that happened and as I say
it's not just a difference of
interpretation of was I standing
upholding a glass at an event which I
didn't think was a party but I thought
was a work event it's the fact that the
committee has been able to establish
that when he came to the dispatch box he
made statements which he knew were
disagreed with by his own officials
who had said well you can't say that
I I think that's that for me that's one
of the most damning aspects of this
report but overall Mr Johnson just
Chucks up smoke screens in all
directions so as I say here's somebody
who says Parliament is really important
after all there's a centerpiece of his
brexit wasn't it parliamentary
Parliament sovereignty must be restored
but when actually the House of Commons
exercises its Sovereign right to
discipline and to investigate A Member
of Parliament who might be in contempt
then it's all complete rubbish he says
it's a vendetta against him he says that
he was rallying the troops he had a
glass in his hand because he was raising
a glass to in support of those that have
been working tirelessly through the
pandemic and in addition to that he says
look at what the Metropolitan Police
said you know they did find me guilty on
one case that was a piece of birthday
cake uh at the start of a meeting
looking at some of the pictures as we're
talking to you that have actually been
highlighted in the report
but the point is did he mislead the
House of Commons as to his motivation
when he turned up to these meetings
um I'm not in a position to comment
although I have to say some of the
meetings look rather like parties when
you look at the photographs they don't
really look like work events but even
assuming that he was put on the spot and
asked that the House of Commons dispatch
box what was going on and what he
replied included quite deliberate lies
you can't just brush that under the
carpet ministers are supposed to give
honest accounts to the House of Commons
on facts and he didn't do it
um what do you make of him uh swiping at
members of the committee including
Bernard Jenkin and indeed the chairman
of the committee well it seems to me to
be all over peace with the way Mr
Johnson behaves at this committee is the
mechanism it's the only mechanism
constitutionally by which the House of
Commons can protect its Privileges and
enforce the standards it expects from
MPS towards them that's what we have and
yet suddenly Mr Johnson just thinks that
this is something which he can criticize
there isn't a shred of evidence that
this committee has acted in a
deliberately biased fashion against him
I served on the standards and privileges
committee and my own experience is that
when MPS come through the door to work
there they do it with a completely
non-partisan way and the people he's
most critical of are people who in the
past were in fact his political allies
and I think that's quite telling because
the idea that they should have a bias
against him seems to me to be rather
improbable I'm just hearing um if you'll
indulge me for a second
um from the liberal Democrats they have
been responding and they've called on
Rishi sunat to strip Boris Johnson of
his ex-priministers allowance following
the publication uh the former prime
ministers are entitled to claim up to
115 000 pounds a year to fund office
costs for life they say that is
inappropriate and it should be cut by
Rishi sunak what do you think well I
think one has to think about that I I
think I'm going to comment on it uh
because ex-prime ministers are entitled
to the allowance and he is an ex-prime
Minister but I have to say his overall
behavior in the course of the last week
as I say breaking the confidence of the
committee by partly releasing at their
findings in a way that he could spin to
his best advantage and now the serial
attack on members of the committee does
raise a whole series of issues about his
Fitness for any form of public role and
so I'm basically something which Mr
sunak may wish to consider but I
wouldn't want I wouldn't want to uh
pronounce on that and just a final
thought before I let you go the
committee itself making the point that
this is unprecedented that no previous
prime minister has been found to be
deliberately misleading the house uh
yeah this is completely unprecedented
but then Mr Johnson is a completely
unprecedented figure after all we know
that he's a man who is a Serial liar and
he lies not only to protect himself he
also lies to smear other people I've
watched it during the course of his
career and he did it when he was prime
minister
so seeing that he did it so routinely
and regularly in a number of other
settings doesn't really come as a
surprise that he lied through his back
teeth about the circumstances relating
to breaches of the rules in number 10
Downing Street can he come back from
this I hope not
I hope he's gone for good uh the country
is much better off without him okay it's
good to see you thank you very much for
joining us